hello and welcome to the to the to the
to this video playing whom boiled Kali
ma
let's see what he is doing against my
dear formals maybe nothing
going five okay maybe this is also a
move trying all kinds of things probably
going to cattle
I know that this is an opening variation
but don't ask me about details c5
there's probably Queen a3
I think they normally play e5 in such
disposition
yeah doesn't doesn't seem like he's
still playing for memory if I forever is
a very logical move I mean even if you
don't know them theoretical implications
you probably should just play it just
looks very logical you remember that
this is somehow the move but I think
makes a bit of sense of course what
development absolutely sucks I mean okay
if I now take on c5 he will play the
Queen to d7 or something I guess
it's probably helpful to have this trade
simply to get rid of the opposite
colored bishops should help to keep more
winning ideas in play
yeah not easy for black I'm not sure if
94 is a real idea but I'm happy with
this this is very nice Queen takes pawn
takes e5 is just very comfortable for
white he has to take in the Queen I mean
I know I don't see much point in taking
with the pawn so there is possibly Queen
age 3 but I just have f3 some not a big
issue
and three is always going to be rather
safe I think okay look at these seven ok
Queen age three and three rogue age five
maybe I have efore him as a totally
different option what this month it
could be annoying him
this looks incredibly shaky as the Queen
is somehow tied to the to the rook
okay now how do we do this is there
anything better for me not less than
this my ideas roopd 7 next
oh my really
[Music]
oh I completely overlooked this one
that's stupid
maybe too slow
trying to go to c3 just keep it
completely safe
okay let's now run the pawn much yeah
I think one of them one of the issues
was somebody the the big-time
disadvantage that was happening he
played this I just found quite quickly
but then he started to take very long
things and as I think we are still
basically in theory George e5 rook c8
this is kind of nice I think they play
e5 here I think the system may move and
it's all supposed to be roughly equal
the way it turned out here I mean I was
very very happy with this this must be
better for white to some extent I think
the structure is just more important
than than the bishop at the moment
look do you one note see 537 okay okay
this is not bad and f3 f3 is very
disliked by the comp you to our queen e5
is strong it not only it has this Queen
III idea but also looked b8 okay so this
is y f3 wasn't good the engine just
wants to play this and this this is
something that I saw but I I didn't see
that Queen e5 is such an issue okay I
hope c8 was played again Queenie fire
No and now route d7 is a bit better but
Queen e7 keeps an edge and now just Ruka
a 7 ok this wasn't so great
I also spotted this there because he has
this move and I can take a seven but
this is not super clear okay the
computer loves wide and plus one but
it's not this is not so easy and the
King is a bit a bit Airy after Queen f6
and the ending is horrendous you know I
didn't I didn't see before and that I
had to do this with 91 but it is fine
and yeah I think the conversion was kind
of was okay and this is not a bad line
for white it's a super safe line if you
learn it with white and know the details
it's very tough for black to ever win as
I mentioned I believe they play this and
then you get then you get this kind of
position where black has some play on
the light squares but a better a better
world spawn structure course okay guys
thanks for watching